michael fulmer has taken the mound as a
starter for the third time this season
you see his record this year one and one
he had a little rough go last time
against pittsburgh but looking to bounce
back from the really good one he had
down in houston
the one two to o'hern gets away from
ramos both runners advance now another
job by ramos that's just not the way you
do it you don't backhand those balls you
got to slide block them keep them in
front
the 2-2
man he got him looking
good way to end the first for michael
fulmer and the royal strand two
here's duffy's numbers
18 innings
one earned run
a shohei ohtani homer no shame in that
oh baby mom what is this an eye tester
or something up there
you got a hack or they'll send you back
that was filthy look at this
he's fought taking a page out of mike
miner
taking the mound today i got to do
better against these guys
now goodrum is down on strikes and
that's back to back
for duffy and then he got goodrum
swinging at a breaking ball
will that be his go-to pitch here
nope fastball up and away so duffy
strikes out the side
[Music]
you gotta read swings a little bit
better and throw pitches in different
sequences he's done that and he
sequenced dozier quite well there
striking him out to start the kc second
tigers in the shift against lopez
the 2-0
grounds right into it to second base and
willie castro handles it
jamer candelario leads off the second
for the tigers then it'll be ramos and
the aforementioned willie castro
that didn't take very long
exactly what is this an eye test out
there let's go
hey
tuffy look at him this is at the park
man
[Music]
scope is reaching
and hits it to right
solaire has it and duffy has two
scoreless innings
it's the tigers long-term plan with both
guys they want to try to get them the
work they want but it's at a at a number
that they think is manageable long term
well if you keep having six pitch
innings like michael fulmer you're gonna
manage things just fine
the people who
oh man that's just tough duffy's hitting
is putting his fastball right where he
wants it be tough to face a guy that's
got all pitches working for him at that
velocity like a lot of downtowns
including kansas city a lot more people
moving into the city center and living
there
the batter is gross when he hits a high
fly ball to center back goes michael
taylor no problem for him and danny
duffy has pitched three scoreless frames
to the fourth we go no score pitching
change scooble piggybacked on
fulmer against pittsburgh on april 21st
last time out through three innings that
was the first time he had pitched in two
years so you have to be careful and he
hits jorge soler on a 2-2 pitch
you know i think he's thrown three
changeups and i don't know if that was a
change-up i don't know what that pitch
was but we used to call it the worm
killer
because it lands in the
dirt in front of home plate
two great royals here's the one two
and he struck him out
chris conroy being a little uh
lenient with his strike zone early in
this game but again we talk about his
consistency
that ball more than likely caught the
plate someplace just because our angle
shows it's off the plate where
wilson ramos catches it he catches it
four or five feet behind the strike zone
dozier strikes out for the second time
scuba blows him away back-to-back
punch-outs
for tarik skubal
that headache may last a while here
another three-two right
in the middle perfect there is good
and they handle ben intending that was
smoked right back up the box google got
out of the way
i think he did yeah chuck and duck
royals are done in the fourth here come
the tigers initially brings in another
pitch
oh change up
so he got him in fastball mode duffy has
struck out cabrera for a second time
today and he has six
great example striking out a hall of
famer after falling behind 3-0 coming
back with some conviction they won a
hundred games three times
goodrum finally does run and the throw
is in time and whit helped him out
pulling down a high throw great changeup
there lower part of the zone whit
got his leg in front of the base there
which was nice
that that kept him from getting his hand
in there salvador perez throwing out
another runner
the 2-2 to ramos
yanked to left ben and tendy watches it
off the wall candelario will hustle to
third ramos puts on the brakes that's a
long hard hit single tigers have runners
at the corners with two away
ramos runs and a fastball strikes him
out
so danny labored some in the fourth
inning but the tigers are scoreless and
now duffy has struck out seven
taylor takes off good pitch to run on a
high breaking ball and
ramos had to wait forever for that thing
to get to home plate taylor's got to be
ready for a wild pitch because this guy
is wild but he figured you just take
matters into his own hands yeah and like
you said pick the perfect pitch to go
looking he's not even looking at home
plate lots of times when you steal third
base you'll take a little peek on your
way to third to see what the catcher's
doing but that slows you down a tick
foamer got wet
on a pop-up to short and a fly out to
center field
and on his hands the infield was in so
it's a long run out for
castro and
taylor ends up scoring on a base hit so
that lead off single sack bunt steal of
third
leads to the game's first run salvi
wants this pitch down
it is
and it's a strikeout duffy's eighth he
had a season-high eight on monday
against the rays and he has eight again
today
now jacoby jones and that's well hit to
right but solaire is there so right
after the royals get a run duffy shuts
down the tigers in the bottom of the
fifth
dozer is struck out twice both times
swinging today
hunter dozier that is a blast to left
field and gone to give the royals a two
nothing lead
hunter dozier has hit eight home runs in
his career against the tigers and every
single one of them
has been in this ballpark man i'll tell
you what that's a welcome sight so danny
duffy goes five innings
he gives up no runs on
four singles
no walks and eight strikeouts and now
third time through and
mike matheny and cal eldred decided it
was time for a fresh arm
cabrera takes the hat trick in his first
game back from the injured list
and royals pitchers have struck out nine
tigers in six innings
and you've got a guy at the plate who's
been very good in these situations this
year
line center field and that's going to
get the royals two more
lopez scores marifield scores it is four
nothing kc with nobody out
in the ninth inning
one hop nikki lopez from the outfield
grass and santana
picks it over on the right side and the
royals
have taken the series